[Music]
the question I get asked more than
anything else lately is how can you
possibly say that Revenge of the Sith
was a good movie but after that and I do
have my reasons
the next most asked question is who do
you trust in the media I'm finding this
question harder and harder to answer
these days which is yet another
indication of how screwed up our
political and social system is right now
at the same time it's hard to know just
how screwy our world is or whether it's
just the loudest and craziest voices
that consistently get amplified on
social media maybe the American
Revolution actually was a bit nuttier
than the history books would tell us but
we'll never know because George
Washington didn't have the chance to
live tweeted without trust we really
don't have the basic underpinnings for a
free and pluralistic society we have to
trust our elected officials will do the
jobs they're sworn in to do and carry
out the promises they said they would
deliver upon we have to trust that our
media will keep the political elite in
check and not just suck up to the powers
that be and we have to trust that our
institutions are strong enough to
withstand corrupt politicians and
totalitarian ideologies that would strip
us from the very freedoms our system was
built upon of course trust without doing
the necessary work to make sure it's
based in logic and reason is really just
faith having faith that our politicians
will do the right thing or that our
media will hold the politicians to
account or that our system will just
function as it should is basically a
recipe for disaster
slowly but surely our freedoms will be
chipped away at because faith isn't what
guarantees our freedoms in the first
place it's the Constitution that does so
Trust is built over time by repeated
evidence that you can actually believe
that when someone says something it's
what they mean you don't believe it
simply because they say it you believe
it because of a track record of a person
consistently following through on their
word this is the opposite of faith which
is built on the idea of believing in
something without evidence we usually
talk about these
essential issues in the context of God
and religion but I think it would serve
us all well to ask some important
questions about these issues right here
and right now so now let me kick the
question back to you
who do you trust in the media I'm
guessing it's a pretty short list though
if you've got some good names I'd love
to hear them in the comment section
right down below now let's go a step
further with that who do you trust in
politics if you're the biggest Trump
supporter out there do you truly trust
everything that he says or do you accept
his untruths because you believe in his
wider agenda accepting a certain amount
of untruth may be the only legitimate
way to view politics and politicians but
when you add a distrust of the media to
a distrust of politicians and then toss
in a heavy dose of social media
craziness we end up with this confused
conversation in which we can't even
agree on basic facts this spot where
nothing is really true and what we feel
overrides what's provable is fertile
ground for those on the extremes to take
root so who do I trust well there's a
wide range of people from sam Harris to
ben shapiro to larry elder to eric
weinstein trusting these people doesn't
mean that they're infallible or that i
agree with everything that they say but
it does mean that i see they have a
commitment to the truth and they have
consistently done their best to put it
out there they don't have all the
answers and I certainly don't either but
I think we're doing our best to find
some truth in the sea of craziness for
those of us who genuinely want to figure
out how to combat the forces who want to
burn down the system or give in to
authoritarian tyranny our work is cut
out for us as for me I trust that it'll
work out because I see more and more of
you speaking out every day you might
just say that a little faith in yourself
goes a long way
[Music]
you